some say it's a natural relationship
because China has cash then Russia has
natural resources so there's a natural
affinity right there well just read the
American literature I'm sure that you
know about that we are just pretending
that you're not familiar with it the
American analytical scientist spa legal
experts speak about registers turning
towards China China is a growing economy
if anyone is a concert with the
declining growth rates then the first
Deputy Chair of Secretary of China a
percent growth the highest in the world
Russia the whole world is turning
towards Asia Europe is interested in it
as well and we are destined to do that
because we are neighbors it is a natural
affinity it is a natural movement and
development besides there are many
values which are common for us which
were protect at the international arena
that is n equal access to addressing
international issues is it a more
natural affinity than Europe and the
United States is China more in the
future a place that Russia feels more
comfortable than with Europe in the
United States and could that lead to
some anti Western alliance
anticipable anti-western the
anti-american alliance between moab xie
well china including us are not
fortunate relations against someone we
are not building alliances against
anyone we're building alliances for
implementing and meeting our own
national interests
I draw attention to the fact you are
expanding the NATO there is no Soviet
Union anymore but NATO was created as a
counterweight to the Soviet Union and
the Warsaw book NATO keeps in expanding
but we wanted to create any military
alliances with China we do not tend to
adopt a block based approach what we're
trying to do is to adopt a global
approach we are trying to distribute the
responsibilities we're striving to find
really acceptable compromises we are
never based on the position of force we
are trying to find new solutions within
the framework of negotiations